marry that was your last Lobby segment
yeah I paddled I'd have a lot so this
was a good one yeah thanks for having me
on
well uh so you've been here three years
yes my friend Rob handler just walked in
the studio Rob came in early yesterday
and was working tirelessly and Benji -
he was working on a robot that it's good
now that i think about it that doesn't
make much sense
he's been g chatting us all secretly and
getting clips together and working on a
fitting send-off at least for our for
your presence on our live show so we
have something that Rob has been working
to put together and uh fiddling stereo
Kirk John hold Opsware turn audio but
John Looby no kidding there we go all
right all right John Luke roll it I
can't believe and do this sawsbuck I
choose you
[Music]
you're probably asking yourself Mary
what kind of video is this here's a list
of things GTA does really well gets
Michelle Pfeiffer's sundries the hip hop
submarine stripper index staff can
bicycle redneck strippers this week on
new releases a little something for
everyone remember there's no wrong way
to twerk on the phone so thank you
I just might guys collect red stars to
make your ship fly Xbox one versus
PlayStation 4 showdown we've got four
consoles set up here okay if I pass the
baton you guys could see a squeaky bear
that mary has I'm a plan Dead Rising 3
my teddy you know cheering Michael and I
got a lot of people join with me I have
a Mary Kish and Eddie makuu
Oh big Mary kiss oh that kind of like if
you could imagine my oh we love we do
this thing
welcome to megabit everyone it's me Pete
with Mary back magic
[Music]
Peter you have to join me
I can't do it no it's all yeah looking
down
workin all my dazzling place I never
knew that's all I can do and I'm Mary
and welcome to another GameSpot plays
I'm here with the lovely Kevin Bernard
all calm and do you say we when you find
yeah I don't really say it I think it in
a way we're going to be playing trine 3
no where is the camera
it's on you are here with Marrakesh yet
tag dot jerk GTA on PC hasn't been out
for too long but the mods are already
starting to come out wrong he's not
allowed to do any much time trying not
to the car not god damn it you think I
don't know about finding happy fourth
chain happy fourth year as well what a
fantastic time we live in
[Music]
my first TGIF but it's my first time in
Japan so I have like zero idea
[Music]
that's where you're able to try out the
different pellet guns that they have
okay guys it's Wednesday October 28th
I'm Mary Kish and you're watching
GameSpot news Batman Arkham Knight is
gonna be the first in the Rocksteady
Studios trilogy to get an M for Mature
rating because they're gonna say [ __ ] in
it hey Mary here with the GameSpot news
update today it was announced that Shaun
is a huge [ __ ]
our second contestant is zero suit Mary
Kish ya ready
what's that guys we got some
construction downstairs we hit a
load-bearing wall we need to get out of
here right now all right right well when
you have Xbox gold or PlayStation Plus
oh my god Josh what we do
you
[Music]
let's be clear you're no way of sound
mind and body
it Josh dad
what's up guys we are so excited to
start this new series with you this is
resident evil
I got now are you bad surprised
alright guys here an e3 2014 right now
there's some creative genius going on
speaks for itself yeah there's
definitely a lot of magic behind the
scenes I think it's probably the second
game in the history of GameSpot that
have made our managers have required
specified times that we're allowed to
play it the new plan is luck lag and
[ __ ] come on Brad [ __ ] it's
become the quintessential game that we
cannot put down in fact there's been
rules in place because we play it so
much that we're starting to get in
trouble gaming is just the best I mean
where else can you put on a headset and
call someone the cops
newbie he's just you and feel really
superior about it it's awesome it's such
a good game play it right now go spend
it the way you want to do it as Joe Dirt
would say life's a garden dig it
[Music]
[Music]
what's really sad thank you
yeah says Rob handler II uh the least
you know he could do or any else could
do send you off you've become
career yeah yeah Rob come over on set
its remoter have a Mike quick that video
sucked to make really hard to make
really hard to make merry has done them
all and obviously someone had to do it
so thank you up did that I thought you
were making a robot come here
yeah obviously you know Mary is going on
to do some new stuff she will have more
news in the coming weeks or months or
whenever she announces her next
adventure
but we're all really sad to see you go I
know like PE been taking spot for a
while I haven't been here long but she's
become a met you become a mentor to me
come over video team and everything and
I'm sad to see you go the office is not
gonna be nearly as fun or we're gonna
have to work really hard to try to keep
the energy up with you gone I love this
place and I'm gonna miss every one of
you guys it's gonna be the hardest it's
hardest thing I've ever done in my life
I'm I'm I love you guys I love you to me
Eve you've been the highlight of
breaking hey this is tough is really
hard yeah working with you has just been
incredible and I'm so happy to call you
a friend so and if you've grown in like
a measurable ways over the years which
is more than I can say for you know some
people and you just consistently impress
me so geez that was a scrappy little
nobody um I fought my way in here and
I'm just so glad I was able to work with
you guys and I'm so excited
I just love GameSpot so much
I think 2017 is gonna be a really good
year and I'm bummed I'm not gonna be
there with you guys but I'll be with you
in spirit I'll thank you guys every step
of the way I am so glad I got the time I
did with you Sam
oh that video I said that's my favorite
part like eight times got all the good
ones whoo yeah it's a it's gonna suck to
see you go um we'll have you back as
often as possible obviously yeah I
always won't come back what you guys are
doing I'll watch you i watch everything
you do yeah well uh it's been fun to
start new projects with you between dead
air the podcast we did for a while
starting work on the lobby producing it
with you and obviously resident Knievel
is always a highlight of our week we
will be continuing that that's right I
had a lot of people ask me what will
happen with Knievel and we made a
promise and we're going to keep it and I
will come back and finish Knievel so I'm
going to just come back once a week and
we're just gonna keep making it so you
can expect episodes of Knievel every
week until we finish all of them as the
plan I'll be I'll be sneaking into the
office somehow like you went through the
air vents security can't stop me now the
cam alright well as always Mary thank
you so much for helping produce this
episode as well as pretty much every
lobby episode ever thank you being
behind the scenes as well as on-camera
for doing all you do can't really sum it
up in ten seconds at the end of an
episode but obviously we'll see you here
the rest of the week we'll have you back
as often as possible if the chat is on
the indication the audience is going to
miss you a ton as well I'm sure you've
gotten a lot of best wishes over Twitter
and whatnot and we're really excited to
see you and now it's what you're doing
next and everything so we know you'll
kick ass like Rob said in the video and
we're looking forward to seeing what you
do thank you guys and thank you guys for
watching and thank you guys for
supporting the lobby and all the shows
that we produce we put our blood sweat
and tears into them and there's a lot of
people that you don't see working back
there to do things like jean-luc and
Eric Tay a lot of other people so a lot
of people work really hard here to make
things
that you guys like so it's good to
acknowledge them Richard Lee Richard Lee
the behind the camera extraordinaire
who's always who's been running the
camera for the lobby for like ever so
there's like no lighting that's done
that he hasn't touched um Jake Decker
does a lot of behind the scenes as well
mm-hmm yeah and like I said your shoes
can never be filled but we'll do our
best to uh keep his site energetic and
you know doing creative stuff in the
meantime when you're gone keep that
energy up Mike I'll try Cal aesthetics
like every every before every show what
you get I do might have a wig anyway
Harley push up that degree we're gonna
weekend and Bernie we're not gonna kill
you but we'll carry around like a dummy
with your wig on we have a dummy in the
office on the highway which you which
was not in the highlight reel that was
actually you doing all those runs yeah I
did every stunt here since I was here so
I will Mary do you want to do the honor
of closing the episode out then sure
right they get cheese I've never done
this before I'll probably mess it up
thank you guys for watching the lobby
this is our weekly show about video
games every Wednesday at 11 a.m. now and
we're so glad you guys could join us and
you guys make the show possible and we
want your opinion and we want to know
what you think so
message us message might party on
Twitter or you guys can leave a note in
the comments so that we know what you
guys want to see more of because we do
it for you and I'm gonna miss you guys
have a great day
[Music]